well I'm joined Now by retired Air by
Sir Marshall Sean Bell to discuss all of
this let's touch on this admission Now
by Iran that they have been supplying
drones to Russia I guess it was
suspected for a while but why are they
admitting it all of a sudden yeah it's
worth a bit of background last couple of
weeks we've been reporting the
widespread targeting of critical
National infrastructure by Russia of on
Ukraine using the Shaheed 136 drones
which Iran at the time said they had not
provided to the Russians
um yet the Iran's net Iranians now have
omitted they have to provided them but
have qualified that saying they've
provided them a couple of months before
the start of the war that's all parts of
Iran trying to position itself not to
take sides in this Russia's used about
300 of these drones so far but it needs
another couple of hundred mile accounts
and it's also looking for Iranian sport
to provide other missiles potentially
surface to our missile systems but
returning to your question of why now it
does appear that Iran's seeking to
exploit this Russian dependency on its
four weapons and seeking to create a
more bilateral more equal partnership
relation ship with Russia what's
interesting I think is Russia desperate
needs the weapons what is it that Iran's
seeking and it's widely reported now
that Iran is actually looking for help
with its fledgling nuclear program and
if that's true that's a very worrying
development let's move on to the latest
situation on the ground here in in
Ukraine breaking down for us yeah
yeah I've been talking a lot about
Hassan President Putin's announced that
he's trying to get civilians evacuated
out of the the city
um is that a precursor to a bigger
withdrawal or is that preparing for
fighting the honest answers we don't
know but it's worth reminding the
viewers that for a Ukrainian perspective
they'd be really reluctant to fight
their way into hearse and that would be
an incredibly difficult and dangerous
undertaking then probably what they're
trying to do at the moment is to isolate
the tens and thousands of Russian troops
that have trapped in Harrison they've
blown the bridges over the nepro river
and cause a real Logistics challenge for
Russia supplying those forces
potentially as the winter goes on from a
military analyst perspective we still
generally believe that Russia will
withdraw but probably a fighting
withdrawal to stop the ukrainians
turning into a route in Donetsk is the
other reason we're looking at massive
Fighting by the Russians it's about the
only part of the country where the
Russians are on the front foot and
pushing really hard if you look at the
luhanska region up the north there
that's already owned and occupied by the
Russians danette's though there's a huge
white area there that the Russians
haven't yet got the Russians are pushing
everything at that attack the ukrainians
said there were 80 attacks in one day
mounted which is a huge effort massive
casualty is almost certainly from the
Russian side to do that why because it
appears that there's a desperate effort
by the Russians to try to take that
before the winter period is part of
Putin's special military operation and
and talk us through the latest on on the
Russian forces uh Sean because they've
also been trying to get the numbers up
but how's that going and what's the sort
of status at the moment yeah it's really
interesting to be focused on quantity
but not on quality they had this partial
mobilization to get 300 000 troops in
addition to that they've now I've got
100 another 120 000 they're trying to
source which is the annual requirement
for Russia to generate replacement for
its conscript Army
um the challenge is who does the
training for these military voters
because all the trainers are actually at
War at the moment so they're doing it up
in Belarus up to the north Belarus is
not known well for its International
defense training so those troops are
hitting the battle really badly trained
we've talked a lot about this training
why it's important good example came out
overnight Russian military commander in
the Dom Mass Alexandra korokovsky
claimed that 60 percent of the Russian
casualties in the donbass were caused by
friendly fire now although Friendly Fire
is an issue for any military it's
normally fractions of percent maybe two
or three percent see it five percent
even if that's been grossly exaggerated
is a dreadful indictment of the Russian
military training why is that happening
they've had several generals replaced
they've got lots of ill-trained
ill-equip forces in place and they've
got a mix of forces and their mercenary
forces and they're badly bad
communication bad command control bad
coordination whatever the challenge is
though this is not going to be an easy
thing for the Russians to fix sure well
as always thanks so much